year was 2047.
this is all that was left
the Great Space Wars between the
muscafarians and the bezosites had
depleted Earth of all its natural
resources
the Bitcoin virus and Uber's robot
chauffeurs had finished the job
the only signs that humans had ever been
here were the ramshackle buildings
and the windmills that kept spinning and
spinning
nothing to power
everyone had abandoned Earth
everyone except for this man
[Music]
he was known as desger Molnar
Porsche
[Music]
there's a modicum of Truth in all of
this
if you want to know what the world will
look like when it's a rundown mess you
can head to the Mojave Desert
it's here that you'll find some of the
world's greatest or at least most
eccentric inventors this craft is the
sexy beast pushing machines to their
limits
it's a place that froths with
engineering passion
and that offers total freedom to
Relentless tinkerers
join me on a road trip across the Mohave
from Los Angeles all the way to Las
Vegas
as we meet people trying to change the
future of cars we are self-driving and
to make space cheap and easy we're
working on point-to-point travel one day
[Music]
thank you
for decades La has been home to two
thriving communities of builders
the people who design cars
and the people who build spaceships
many of them work in polished Studios
and massive industrial buildings
but the man I'm looking for Works in a
place like this
treasure how are you
good to see you man
this is Desert Molnar
and this is where it keeps his toys so
when we're driving slow we keep the
landing gear down and then once we hit
the freeway and we're in second gear
I'll bring the wheels up so don't freak
out when you hear that sound
[Music]
desert used to fly planes in the Air
Force then he built Rockets
and rocket-powered cars
he's been in some bands
he's been rich
he's been poor he's a free spirit who
does whatever he wants
like a lot of angelinos treasure often
finds himself stuck for hours on the
freeway
wishing there was a way to rise up and
escape from the concrete prison this is
my first attempt at a flying car
[Music]
the flying car as as a development has
often been mired in the idea that you
have to make something for everybody and
that you have to dumb it down so that
it's a consumer product to cut a few
seconds off of somebody's commute
[Music]
I don't have the objective about
creating ubiquity Da Vinci did one copy
of the Mona Lisa and it wasn't for
everybody and it wasn't like he had to
make 500 of them but it still has value
and I see a lot of the machines that
have been made as art pieces and I think
what they need is a gallery right now to
help Drive the interest and the
development
to drum up that interest desert soon
plans to start a flying car racing
league in the Mojave Desert
there's a long-standing marriage between
LA and the Mojave
it's in La where Engineers go about
their day jobs and fancy offices
and it's in the Mojave where the folks
who can never stop experimenting go to
try out their ideas on the weekends
Mojave is sort of what it's like the
the playground for the test bed it's
about the people you want to meet as
opposed to people that you don't need
it's those are the freaks you know that
that matter to me are the ones that want
to go out there and take their 300 mile
an hour jet car out on a Saturday
afternoon yeah whatever all right I'll
see you at the freeze okay
you can join the club
foreign
is about a two-hour drive into the
California Desert from Los Angeles
and most of that time is spent staring
at bumpers
traffic sucks you deal with this and yes
the flying car seems like a great idea
but as we made our way out into the
inventor Badlands the reality of zipping
across the desert in a loose assembly of
metal pipes and good intentions felt
somewhere between stupid and terrifying
[Music]
though is that much of this technology
is tried and true
the first part of deja's flying car plan
hinges on this gyrocopter
[Music]
these types of vehicles have been flying
since the 1920s
they're cheap relatively easy to build
and pretty reliable
instead of running on a motor the
propeller gets its lift from the wind as
the craft goes forward
[Music]
it's incredible man it's crazy you just
got like this totally different
perspective
if the engine cuts out the copter would
just flutter down to the ground like a
leaf falling out of a tree
my adrenaline was pumping right before
we took off but you know like the second
we were in the air I mean you just yeah
there's a lot to see and it's pretty
here I sort of forget about it all yeah
and as you saw I mean obviously there's
we can land anywhere out here yeah so
it's a perfect place
the gyrocopter takes care of the up part
of the flying car puzzle
but you still need something to deal
with the roads
for that desert has this slick concept
vehicle
the goal is to marry the two and have
something that turns just about any road
into a Runway
the select few willing to give it a go
will taste freedom while the rest of us
rot on the 405. I think that the reality
is that a lot of people in this world
like to have some kind of an advantage
in life no matter what they're doing
whether it's a bigger stereo or a you
know a swimming pool at their house
but the reality is that in nature all
birds can walk all bugs that fly have
legs and they can fold their wings up on
their back
they survive in different environments
because they've adapted to get through
them to say that we're going to spend 40
billion hours a year in the United
States sitting in traffic saying that
well no one will ever have one of these
I don't really care if that's the party
line
[Music]
you can make something that will allow
you to escape this ridiculous ant line
of Eternity
[Music]
out here in the Mojave there's testing
Rockets
and then there's testing Rockets
to be a kick-ass rocket company you know
you need to test a lot
the folks who succeed are able to
iterate quickly
many of America's top rocketeers work
here
it's the Mojave airport which is
situated smack dab in the center of
Mojave the town
this is where the big kids play with
fire and the pyromaniacs over at Virgin
Galactic hope to soon offered tourists a
chance to visit space
for about 250 000 per ticket
we're about twice that on StubHub
George Whitesides is a NASA veteran and
serves as the CEO of Virgin Galactic he
gave me a tour of their operation which
includes a test stand for breaking in
rocket engines nature does not like what
we're trying to do here the art of this
is taking something that nature doesn't
want and sort of bending it into an
outcome virgin spaceship will be carried
into the air underneath the plane the
spaceship will then fire up its own
thrusters and head for the heavens
it's a complex system and there are a
few places on Earth where you can work
out the Kinks it's the only place in the
United States where you can design
manufacture and test a rocket motor and
then integrate it on a spaceship and fly
it into space you know this is this is
really the frontier of American
Aerospace virgin wants to offer more
than just a joyride it thinks people
visiting space even for just a few
minutes will have a profound effect on
how we all see our planet you know so
we've got 700 People Order magnitude
signed up to go on our spaceship that's
more than the number of people who have
ever been to space in 50 years
but they're going to go back to
communities all over the world and
they're going to bring that perspective
with them and I think that's going to
have a really important effect
the story of Virgin has been one of
great promise and devastating setbacks
in 2014 the company's first spaceship
crashed to the ground killing the
co-pilot and injuring the pilot
today at this press event virgin hopes
to restore confidence in its technology
by unveiling spaceship 2 Richard
Branson's attempt to resurrect the
Galactic Empire From the Ashes
[Music]
this one has taken more than 10 years
you're still not at the point where
we're flying yet how difficult has this
business been compared to your others it
is rocket science it is really difficult
we're just Reinventing the wheel
completely Reinventing the technology so
um it's been tough but we now have you
know rockets that we know will take us
to space you know we feel confident that
we're finally very very close to being
there ever a good and devoted son
Branson decorated the spaceship with his
mother's likeness and ever the good
showman used the spaceships unveiling as
an excuse to throw a birthday party for
his granddaughter that's a bottle of
milk made out of sugar and used for the
kissing
in 2014 after the accident how close
were you to Colleen I don't think I've
ever given up on anything in life
um but we would have been irresponsible
not to ask the questions
[Music]
the important thing is not to um hurry a
program like this the important thing is
to get it right and make sure it's safe
for people to go up and
um and that we offer return tickets not
single tickets
okay
it's the sort of invitation you wait a
lifetime to receive
Mojave
[Music]
we're camping out next to the Trona
Pinnacles
they're weird and beautiful he said
there will be beers and burgers and
tequila and a bunch of gear heads and
techno freaks hanging out together
[Music]
we're gonna show you how we're
Reinventing cars he says
and we're gonna go spine crushing fast
this is mouse McCoy
this is sort of hot rod renaissance man
with a vision
one where the cars of Tomorrow are
designed by artificial intelligence
[Music]
right now we're in this space where like
this stuff seemed like science fiction
but it's actually science fact like
we're living science fact right before
our eyes and to be a part of it just
feels feels good though
House's latest Venture is called hack
Rod the goal is to blend human emotion
and Technology to Spur an automotive
Revolution
to do this Mouse and his team measure
everything they can they wire up cars
with dozens of sensors to see how the
metal performs
then they create 3D maps of their racing
courses to figure out exactly how the
car behaves and on top of all that they
strap brainwave monitors on their heads
to detect stress
I think it's safe to say that as I strap
in for today's test I showing signs of
anxiety already hopefully we'll see pure
panic in the brain monitor
the hot rod team doesn't start with an
off-the-shelf car chassis
use artificial intelligence software to
come up with designs and fabricate them
on a 3D printer
design software and new manufacturing
techniques have gotten good enough to
allow a small group of people to build
custom cars from scratch we're getting
in this Mass world where it just design
decisions are dictated your aesthetic is
dictated by some corporate strategy
somewhere and it's like
that was that hot rod or you know sort
of thing and a lot of our mission here
is going to be about individualization
like having your own design having your
own vehicle
is a full car Felix halls used to
oversee the Hot Wheels and Matchbox
brands for Mattel
he's a Car Junkie who quit the Mattel
gig to start hack rod with mouse we
think this may be the first chassis
that's been engineered with artificial
intelligence
that AI sucks up data collected from the
desert field tests
Felix gives it a few guidelines and it
spits out a body design
feed the data back in and get an even
better car out
what used to take years and hundreds of
Engineers can now be done in a matter of
months or so hackerod hopes to prove we
both come from a kind of hot rod culture
the hacker culture and we looked at this
as like look we're not Ford or Ferrari
or whoever we don't have hundreds and
hundreds of Engineers to start designing
a chassis from the ground up there's a
real democratization of creativity and
design going on that we that we that we
stand for
[Applause]
[Music]
called The Mule it was the first built
using hack rod technology
and it's been utterly abused by Mouse
over the course of three days
soon it will be time to head back to LA
and let the computers do their work to
replace it with mule 2.0
what's your vision for where this
company is in like five years in five
years I think we will have been a
significant driver in the automatic
manufacturing world that's coming
[Applause]
after spending a couple of days at Trona
getting covered in grease and dust
[Music]
so much dust
I plotted my escape from the Mojave
my final stop would be Las Vegas
given the nature of this trip I couldn't
just hop in any old Honda
I needed something special
something that would leave a mark on Sin
City
so I hit up an old friend who happens to
have his own homemade self-driving car
problem solved
we're a couple miles out of Barstow when
the acid kicked in
where Hunter S Thompson had Dr Gonzo as
a companion I have this guy George hotz
he comes with less drugs but plenty of
fear and loathing
hotz became famous as a teenager for
hacking everything in sight
you hacked the iPhone we hacked the Sony
PlayStation he has the legal fees to
prove it
and now he's hacking cars
he stunned the world last year by
building this self-driving car by
himself in his San Francisco Garage in
just a couple of months
[Music]
back then to see his Acura packed full
of cameras Radars and artificial
intelligence software
's and Googles of the world Potts
doesn't give his car a Litany of rules
to follow he basically just drives the
thing and the car learns to mimic the
behavior and does so better and better
over time don't get off the exit
exit oh good job car
hot hasn't bested Knight Rider yet but
he has achieved hasselhoff-esque Heights
of confidence
meanwhile back on the road to Vegas
soon we'll probably be able to drive
without radar just using the camera just
using a camera and cameras
like our cell phone that camera is good
enough to drive the car
I could keep bashing everyone like I'm
the underdog but am I really the
underdog
I have a working self-driving car
not everyone appreciates hot's unique
brand of gusto
the California DMV for example recently
told hotz to quit driving his
experiments on the state's roads this is
why we've had to head to the Nevada
border
where the true freedom of the Mojave
lives on
we're getting close to the Border I'll
press the button once we hit the Border
why can't we do it in California they
don't like Innovation
Nevada loves Innovation that's what I
heard
oh I see the side I see the sign
prepare to engage
on your command Captain all right here
we go welcome to Nevada
three the silver state two one
we are self-driving
hutz's car had never seen the Nevada
roads before but it drove perfectly on
its own for miles
that is until the Desert Sun dipped down
casting Shadows across the road it's
actually the worst time of day for it uh
the contrast is not very good because
the sun is so bright still and the road
is so dim
and like you see now now I can't drive
wow
look I can't see anything in the picture
this is really bad
what does this make you think is this
something you can fix over time
a lot of this has to do with camera
a lot of the bug right now is just
because the camera can't see
[Music]
I finally made our way onto the Vegas
Strip
I tried to cheer him up well let's just
see what happens
go too soon it might go too soon
oh no it sees them there it sees them
there yeah go car goes
here we go
[Music]
don't hit the van don't hit the van
very nice
oh
it's closer than it should have gone
hats's car passed the test and his
existential angst lifted
the legend of Dr hotz Lives on
feeling better now yeah that was good
that was good
[Music]
it's easy to be cynical these days and
knock America
it's the place with the tubby people
who forgot how to make things and who
don't like to get their hands dirty
anymore
but then you come somewhere like Mojave
[Music]
this
is Colossus
[Music]
it came to life here in England at
Bletchley Park in 1943.
[Music]
machine raced to decrypt German messages
by analyzing thousands of words of coded
text every second
[Music]
with its mix of vacuum tubes wires and
switches
Colossus emerged as the first electronic
programmable computer
its arrival gave the Allies a huge Edge
in World War II and saved thousands of
lives
it also marked the start of the
information age
[Music]
England built 10 of the Colossus
machines
and they became the heart of its booming
Computing industry
[Applause]
actually no
this is a replica of Colossus the real
machines were destroyed after the war so
that the pesky Russians wouldn't find
out about the technology
the metaphor then is a simple one
England dismantled Decades of pioneering
Computing work because it seemed like
the proper thing to do
and it suffered the consequences ever
since
I doubt many of you can name a single
tech product or startup that hails from
this country
[Applause]
what you'll see next then may come as a
real shock
because in its very subdued
self-effacing way England has in fact
given rise to a handful of tech
companies that have impacted the world
on an immense scale
I'm heading from London to Cambridge and
into the English Countryside
to find the best technology that England
has to offer along the way there will be
fancy hair dryers and AI infused
software hello my name is Oba what is
your name
of course there will be a spot of tea
if you tried to design the perfect
University Town you would probably fail
to think up something as idyllic as
Cambridge
it's a city filled with temples to
learning and young privileged brainiacs
hop on a bike and you can go on a ride
through academic history
from Newton's Apple Tree
right on up to the pub where Watson and
Crick drink to celebrate the discovery
of DNA's double helix
that seems boring you can also be
ritually abused at the old Cambridge
Market
thanks
oh
it's like sour soap
[Laughter]
today Cambridge also serves as the heart
of England's tech industry with its
research centers startups and massive
biotech firms
outside of the university the biggest
reason for cambridge's technology
success is a company called arm
it designs chips and they're the brains
at the center of almost every iPhone and
Android smartphone
in short the modern world runs on arm
I've met up with my old friends an armed
co-founder Mike Muller to share a warm
British beer and find out how this
happened we're in a pub what is a pub
meant to arm over its history we met our
first CEO in our Pub we are in the pub
that's about 100 yards away from where
we actually started and in those days we
used to come here every lunch time so
yeah it's played an important part in
the business right
foreign
started on something of a whim
his first major customer was Apple which
needed a chip for its upcoming Newton
handheld device
instead of making a screaming fast super
hot chip like everyone else
arm decided to make a low power energy
efficient chip
soon enough making low power chips
became arm's thing it took a while for
the BET to pay off but once mobile
phones and then smartphones arrived arm
ended up as a major force a lifetime our
partners have shipped over 80 billion
different ships and last year there was
about two per person on the planet so
that's about 15 billion arm chip shipped
so they're in everything phones printers
anti-lock brakes televisions Wi-Fi
routers Cloud servers medical devices I
could keep going
to Mueller's point one of the most
Innovative and glorious things built
around an armchip is raspberry pie
[Music]
it might not look like much but this 35
assembly of electronics is a fully
functioning computer
there's the arm chip right here tons of
USB ports an ethernet port even an HDMI
port
with this teeny little thing you can do
just about anything released in 2012 The
Pie has inspired near religious devotion
among geeky hobbyists and inventors
some of them show off their pie
creations at things called raspberry
jams
I went to see David Pride who has a
shrine to the low-cost personal computer
at his home in Gloucester
what is this little device meant to you
it's changed my life I was very happy
very stable I had a nice well-paid job
but I was very very bored and I realized
that point if I wanted to do something
different this was this was the
opportunity to learn the skills that I'd
always wanted to learn Electronics
robotics coding
[Music]
creations
to robots greetings to everyone watching
hello world
that's a nice touch
his most famous invention though is the
four bite an AI infused machine that
plays a meme albeit slow game of Connect
Four
that is cool
how long did it take you to make this
about three months of evenings and
weekends
so it makes it oh no I have to go you
make your move
but it's now thinking about the move
it's taken
oh you're bastard you've just lost
I feel ashamed
I feel like I should have done more for
the humans
to really understand the soul of the
Raspberry Pi I had to head back to its
birthplace in Cambridge and take a boat
trip with Evan Upton he's the computer
scientist that invented the pie
[Music]
around 2007 Eben grew alarmed by the
declining number of computer science
students in England and decided to try
and Inspire the youngsters with a new
approach I've always assumed Cambridge
is the best place in the world to study
computer science so certainly the best
place in the UK and we saw this collapse
in the number of people applying to
study computer science at the University
of Cambridge which is crazy as the
Computing industry is blowing up yeah
communities playing obviously it's a
beautiful it's a beautiful environment
to come and to come and study in the
theory we came up with was that
um most of us who were arriving in the
mid 90s like I did had grown up with
cheap programmable 8-bit microcomputers
you grew up using the BBC micro that's
what got you yeah that's it I had a BBC
micro at school and sat in the corner of
the classroom
and those were beautiful machines
[Music]
supported by the UK government the BBC
micro gave many students their first
taste of coding and the possibility of
what computers could do I'm just gonna
scroll up the pie has very much followed
in this tradition
[Music]
and emerged as a consumer hit along the
way
it's now the third best-selling computer
of all time behind the mac and the PC
our lifetime dream volume was 10 000
units now we're closing on 10 million
but as that's happened we've just got
more ambitious we've just got more
greedy I guess about what we're trying
to accomplish we've gone from can we
move the needle from 200 to 600 people
applying to computer science at
Cambridge to you know can we do the same
for other universities can we do the
same for other countries could we do the
same for other subjects
big Jason Statham impersonator think big
the intellectual underpinnings of
computing began here in Cambridge
in 1833 the Cambridge trained
mathematician Charles Babbage built a
prototype of this thing the Difference
Engine
it can solve equations with the turn of
a crank and some gears and is considered
the first mechanical computer
a hundred years later in the 1930s
another Cambridge mathematician named
Alan Turing devised the concepts behind
the modern day computer
prove that a machine can be programmed
to calculate just about anything
decades after touring and Babbage
Cambridge is still at The Cutting Edge
of computing
[Music]
companies like Microsoft Place their
research centers here to tap into the
local academic talent and to explore
their most ambitious ideas
Chris Bishop runs this lab and oversees
research in a number of areas
one of the most compelling and
frightening areas is artificial
intelligence
[Music]
this is just amazingly exciting time in
artificial intelligence
[Music]
more and more tasks are becoming solved
in image understanding in the speech
recognition and so on it's although
we've got a very long way to go before
we get to the the full capabilities of
the human brain there is a sense that
for some kinds of tasks sort of the
barriers have been removed
computer scientists have dreamed of
creating a true artificial intelligence
for decades
they've been hunting for a machine that
can equal or surpass humans
recently people like Bishop have started
to make real Headway thanks to an
approach called machine learning
if you go back to the time of cheering
Computing is about logic it's about
determinism
and the the code the instructions which
the computer runs are created by a human
what we're seeing in machine learning is
something very different instead of
programming the computer to solve the
task you program the computer to learn
from experience and then we train the
computer by showing lots of examples
giving it lots of data
[Applause]
experiments here including this computer
vision simulation
Microsoft's connect sensor used to
struggle to make out of hand and now it
can pinpoint the movement of fingers
there's also an AI powered movie
recommendation algorithm for Xbox that
does a pretty good job at figuring out
my eclectic taste in movies you know
actually I mean I did like twister okay
let's see what happens this time so now
we see a big change
this lab isn't just about entertainment
though they're actually saving lives
with a program that can tell the
difference between cancerous brain
tissue and healthy tissue in an MRI what
you see here is a pretty nasty brain
tumor so what the machine learning is
doing now is it's labeling it according
to whether it's tissue that's already
dyed or whether it's tissue that is
cancerous and proliferating this is
really important because this is used to
design treatment so we'll fire in
radiation from lots of different
directions and we'll tune up the amounts
and direction of the radiation to try
and kill as much of the cancer as
possible but to do as little damage to
the normal tissue as we can
down the street from Microsoft there's a
startup that already has its AI
technology in the wild
it's called audio analytic and you can
think of it as a type of Shazam for real
world sounds we use artificial
intelligence to allow smart home devices
to recognize a whole range of different
signs that happen inside your houses
it can make your house a bit secure by
detecting glass windows being broken and
then turning your lights to scare where
in the burger actually taking active
protection of you know things you care
about
[Music]
so what do we have here what what is all
this
um so we've got a couple of devices that
make the sounds that uh this detects a
smoke alarm
yeah you see it's detected smoke alarm
on there nobody's at home so it's now
sending a iMessage another sound
um this is glass break
yeah set that off you can see it says
window broken yeah
what is the science behind all of us we
had to do a whole bunch of innovation in
terms of understanding sounds how to
detect them how to have a machine
understand them even if we take a simple
sound like a smoke alarm
there's beep
well now we've got two of them going
beep at different times
with a whole bunch of background noise
going on
that's a big AI problem to solve
computers have to be trained to
distinguish one sound from another and
to learn the unique signature of say
glass breaking
of course no two breaking Windows sound
exactly alike
so these guys get to relieve stress by
breaking a lot of glass
how many windows have you had to break
Windows we've literally filled
warehouses for it on months on end
different sizes different thicknesses
different type of glass
how many smoke alarms smoke alarms we've
literally bought all smoke alarms you
can find on the marketplace and then
index to all of those that was a huge
undertaking logistically
software can also recognize the sound of
a baby crying hi Daisy oh
hi and his luck would have it we found a
cute hungry baby on which to experiment
so you can see on the screen it's
detecting the baby cry
[Music]
audio analytics software already ships
inside a number of Smart Home Products
and the company plans on adding many
more sounds
there we go but for now it's the perfect
technology to discover when an angry
baby has thrown a smoke alarm through a
window
[Music]
I arrived in England at the height of
brexit mania
[Music]
the tourists were happy because the
entire country had gone on sale
some of the locals were morose and some
of them just didn't care like the people
drinking these 20 cocktails at a fancy
hotel bar
nothing says hello to financial ruin
like sipping rum from an elephant made
of Legos or Gin from whatever this is
you know who else doesn't care about
brexit
people willing to pay 400 for a hair
dryer
[Music]
Dyson as we all know has perfected suck
now it's on to blow
meet the supersonic
according to the ample Dyson propaganda
this is the smartest hair dryer ever
built
it uses an electric digital motor to
produce an intense stream of air and
then sensors to make sure that air never
gets too hot
as a result your hair comes out shinier
and healthier than ever before
I feel like I'm two inches taller now
to see how Dyson built this thing
I had to leave London and head to the
company's headquarters in the
picturesque town of malmsbury
[Music]
James Dyson founded this company in 1991
and has created his very own engineering
Paradise
the Dyson campus is littered with his
toys of course you have a plane in the
cafeteria
they're made up of a handful of
invention factories
my first stop is with someone who leads
a constant battle to come up with ideas
for brand new products
and reinvent some old ones
[Music]
hair drawers just haven't changed in
sort of 60 years
if we look at this this cutaway here
he said they've got a very large motor
inside like that but that weight you're
holding you know for 20 minutes half an
hour while you're drying your hair and
very very noisy so we thought it's a
really good product for us to get into
foreign
Dyson spent four years and 71 million
dollars to bring the supersonic to life
and as you might expect their obsessive
compulsive when it comes to Hair We felt
that we had to learn everything about
hair the science of hair we had to build
our end laboratory to learn about hair
for ourselves and learn what causes
damage what causes shine what makes your
hair look lovely
[Music]
he spent more than a decade developing
the core of so many Dyson products
the vacuums have big motors
and the hair dryer has this tiny thing a
miniature turbine this is more tuned to
a jet engine you find on a commercial
airline than anything else
how fast does it spin around 115
000 RPM so that's about 1800 revolutions
every second yeah it seems almost
impossible it's possible through very
fast electronics and a mechanical system
that is able to take the stresses the
strains for hundreds of hours at full
speed
foreign
technology will be key to Dyson's
continued push into new product areas
some people say it's secretly working on
an electric car
what types of things would this be
useful in
um well at the moment we've applied it
to the hair dryer I'll have to wait and
see what comes next I knew you would say
that I can only say that
the drive to invent and salesmanship
president Dyson is something of an
anomaly here
England's beloved cynicism runs counter
to the hype field optimism that
dominates the tech industry
the Brits do a fine job at promoting a
pub lunch
but do less well at spurring on
entrepreneurs and inventors
that when the English really gets into
something they do it well
it's not hyperbole to say that arms
chips have changed the world
where the Raspberry Pi May well have
altered a generation for the better
and if you're inclined to try and think
big there remains no better place to do
it than in Cambridge where you can
meditate in peace among the cows
this fall breaks out in Canada I'm
reminded of all the beauty innocence and
gun-free fun available from our
neighbors to the north
[Applause]
there's the Majesty of Toronto
vast hockey race
[Applause]
and gallons of maple syrup that you can
chug openly and guilt-free for this
maple syrup is pure and nourishing
[Applause]
[Music]
the changing of the seasons also happens
to be the perfect time to encounter one
of Canada's most prized creatures
the artificial intelligence nerd
ever since people first came up with the
idea of computers they've dreamed of
imbuing them with artificial
intelligence
am a smart fellow
S I have a very fine brain that's the
most remarkable thing I've ever seen
the AI is just a computer that is able
to mimic or simulate human thought or
human behavior within that there's a
subset called machine learning that is
now the underpinning of what is most
exciting about AI
by allowing computers to learn how to
solve problems on their own machine
learning has made a series of
breakthroughs that once seemed nearly
impossible
it's the reason computers can understand
your voice spot a friend's face in a
photo and steer a card
and it's the reason people are actively
talking about the arrival of human-like
AI
and whether that would be a good thing
for a horrific end of days thing
[Music]
many people made this moment possible
but one figure Towers Above the Rest
I've come to the University of Toronto
to see the man they call the Godfather
of modern artificial intelligence
Jeff Hinton
[Music]
because of a back condition Jeff Hinton
hasn't been able to sit down for more
than 12 years
sorry well at least now standing desks
are fashionable and yeah but I was ahead
I was standing where I was standing when
they were
since he can't sit in the car or on a
bus Hinton walks everywhere
[Music]
the walk says a lot about Hinton and his
resolved
for nearly 40 years Hinton has been
trying to get computers to learn like
people do a quest almost everyone
thought was crazy or at least hopeless
right up until the moment it
revolutionized the field
Google thinks this is the future of the
company Amazon thinks the vision company
Apple thinks it's a future company my
own Department thinks this does probably
nonsense and we shouldn't be doing
anymore
so I took everybody into it except my
own Department
Chef Hansen pretty early on became
obsessed with this idea of figuring out
how the mind works
he started off getting into physiology
the anatomy of how the brain worked then
he got into psychology and then finally
he settled on more of a computer science
approach to modeling the brain and got
into artificial intelligence
my feeling is if you want to understand
a really complicated device like a brain
you should build one
I mean you could look at cars and you
could think you could understand cars
when you try and build a car you
suddenly discover that there's this
stuff that has to go under the hood
otherwise it doesn't work yes
as chap was starting to think about
these ideas he got inspired by some AI
researchers across the pond
specifically this guy Frank rosenblatt
rosenblatt in the late 1950s developed
what he called a perceptron and it was a
neural network a Computing system that
would mimic the brain
the basic idea is a collection of small
units called neurons these are little
Computing units but they're actually
modeled on the way that the human brain
does its computation
they take incoming data like we do from
our senses and they actually learn so
the neural net can learn to make
decisions over time
was that you could feed a neural network
a bunch of data like pictures of men and
women and it would eventually learn how
to tell them apart
just like humans do
there was just one problem
it didn't work very well
rosenblatt his neural network was the
single layer of neurons
and it was limited in what it could do
extremely Limited
and a colleague of his wrote a book in
the late 60s that showed these
limitations
and
the whole area of research into a deep
freeze for a good 10 years
no one wanted to work in this area they
were sure it would never work
[Music]
it's to me that it was the right way to
go the brain's a big neural network and
so it has to be that stuff like this can
work because it works in our brains
there's just never any doubt about that
what do you think it was inside of you
that
kept you wanting to pursue this when
everyone else was giving up just that
you thought it was the right direction
to go now that everyone else was wrong
okay
Hinton decides he's got an idea of how
these neural Nets might work and he's
going to pursue it no matter what
[Applause]
for a little while he's bouncing around
research institutions in the U.S
he kind of gets fed up that most of them
are funded by the defense department and
he starts looking for somewhere else he
can go
he suddenly hears the Canada might be
interested in funding artificial
intelligence
and that was very attractive so I could
go off to this civilized town and just
get on with it
so I came to the University of Toronto
and then in the mid 80s we discovered
how to remain more complicated neural
Nets so they could solve those problems
that the simple ones couldn't solve
these collaborators developed a
multi-layered neural network a deep
neural network
and this started to work in a lot of
ways but again they hit a ceiling
through the 90s into the 2000s Jeff was
one of only a handful of people on the
planet who are still pursuing this
technology
he would show up at academic conferences
and be banished to the back rooms he was
treated as really like a pariah
but Jeff was consumed by this and
couldn't stop
he just kept pursuing the idea that
computers could learn until about 2006
when the world catches up to hinton's
ideas
[Music]
computers with Arnold Foster and now
it's behaving like I thought it would
behave in the mid 80s it's solving
everything the arrival of super fast
chips and the massive amounts of data
produced on the internet gave hinton's
algorithms a magical boost
suddenly computers could identify what
was in an image
then they could recognize speech and
translate from one language to another
by 2012 words like neural Nets and
machine learning were popping up on the
front page of the New York Times
next up we have Professor Jeffrey Hinton
of the University of Toronto
[Applause]
for hits in this is obviously a really
Redemptive moment
now he's basically a technology
celebrity
and for Canada it's the country's moment
as well
they have more AI researchers than just
about any other place on the planet and
the quest now is to see what these guys
can do starting companies and pushing
the technology forward
s on a journey across Canada to see the
best in Canadian AI technology and to
get a feel for how far the technology
has come and how far it still has to go
[Music]
thank you
here is a city that gets right at the
central tension of Modern Life in the
unfolding AI Revolution
thank you
[Music]
it's Montreal a place filled with beauty
and Old World charms
that asks you to move slowly through its
streets
[Music]
and to chill for a while
reflect and think Deep Thoughts
at the same time it's one of the world's
top AI research centers students flock
here from all over the globe to get deep
with machine learning and to take Jeff
hinton's ideas and figure out how to
turn them into products we all use
they've been
no further than your pocket
all this stuff started out as hardcore
computer science but over the last five
years AI has invaded our everyday lives
your smartphone is packed full of AI
powered apps including something like
Google translate that lets you point
your phone at a magazine that's written
in French and read it as if you were a
local
Engineers have been trying to get
computers to translate text like this
for decades but it was Jeff's neural
Nets that finally made it possible
it's Jeff
and it's not just your smartphone
that works or
for the open road off we go
be my friend Stefan
head of Montreal's Tesla fan club
I'm driving a Tesla for a little bit
more than four years and a half so you
have people asking you for rides all the
time yes
maybe that's because of Fancy Pants
autopilot
Tesla's semi-autonomous driving system
that kicks in when road conditions are
right
so that's it autopilot's on yes and he's
driving by itself
so we need to pay attention
that's we don't have to drive
yeah it's crazy
[Music]
self-driving cars are packed full of
cameras sensors and radar when teamed
with computer vision neural Nets it's
this technology that lets the cars build
a picture of the world
the technology has a long way to go but
this Tesla can monitor all the cars
around it switch lanes and park all by
itself
thanks Jeff so you're living in the
future yeah you know when you try it
once it's very difficult
to do without it because I just can be
relaxed
and we can drive like this
there's a stop sign because that's why
we still need to pay attention
[Music]
a big part of hinton's Legacy lies
Beyond these examples of AI in the world
so inspired a legion of disciples
spreading the good word of neural Nets
[Music]
Joshua bengio is a professor at the
University of Montreal he's one of the
researchers who glommed on to hinton's
ideas when it seemed to make little
sense to do so
[Music]
and together they've come up with many
of the key Concepts behind modern AI
you guys worked on this stuff through
the 80s 90s the 2000s and then it just
seemed like this totally went from
computer science and research to we see
it everywhere in our lives are you you
know or even you surprised what's
happened the last five years that it
really is like sitting on all our phones
and the rate at which the progress and
the Industrial Products have been coming
out is totally something we didn't
expect
even now it's hard to predict where are
we going is it going to slow down
or are we going to continue with this
exponential increase
[Music]
the yahshua that Montreal is full of
top-notch AI graduate Talent
in turn has brought Tech giants like
Google and Facebook to tell along with
their ample checkbooks
to me it seems like if you're good at AI
you can make two three hundred thousand
dollars a year this is crazy to see how
much these guys get paid now a million
dollars is something quite common as a
salary have you ever had a country offer
you an incredible amount of money to
come set up a lab there not a country
but yeah companies yeah
[Music]
but yahshua has rejected the lucrative
offers of big neural net
he remains committed to the Ivory Towers
of Academia which is a better fit for
his philosophical approach to AI
you've got guys like Elon Musk and
Stephen Hawking that sometimes paint
this technology in a very very dark
light that it could run amok and start
doing things on its own what you know
what do you feel when you hear people
say things like that I'm not concerned
about technology running amok of the
Terminator scenario I think is not very
credible and I also believe that if
we're able to build machines that are as
smart as us they also smart enough to
understand our values and to understand
our moral system and and so
in a way that's good for us now I think
there are real concerns which is
essentially misuse of AI to influence
people's minds it's already happening
with political advertising yeah I mean
we've already seen like the stuff from
Facebook so I think we should be careful
about this
and try to regulate the use of AI in
places where it's morally wrong
ethically wrong I think we just should
just ban it and make it you know illegal
[Music]
it's comforting that yahshua has these
concerns
but hop down the road from the
University and reality but what's left
of it becomes Messier
this tiny room is the home to a startup
called lyrebird
it was founded by yahshua's former
students and has built an app that can
clone your voice
are you speaking about this new
algorithm to copy voices this is huge it
can make us say anything now really
anything
one of its Founders is this
is this Mexican expat Jose
he taught me the art of the Clone
so you'll need to record yourself for a
few minutes of audio
thousands of letters danced across the
amateur author's screen
when you start to eat like this
something is the matter
you guys better quit politics and take
in washing
I don't know where that one came from
okay so create my digital voice now
creating your digital voice takes at
least one minute one minute my God yeah
so before to create some artificial
voice of someone you would need to
record yourself for at least eight hours
test your voice all right so now I get
to type something yeah so the moment of
the truth okay
that's liar Birds AI
is Magic after I'm done typing oh I
gotta spell better
any words I put into the app can be
played back in my digital voice
and here's the crazy thing
even words I never actually said in the
first place artificial intelligence
technology seems to be advancing very
quickly should we be afraid
I mean I can definitely hear my voice in
there that's that is that's really
interesting I just picked those words at
random and I definitely did not say some
of them and it's like Flawless and being
able to sort of pick from just about any
word and manufacture it
[Music]
thank you
this technology seems sweet
[Music]
ah but lends itself to all manner of
trickery
[Applause]
I've popped back to my hotel to test out
the library technology a little bit and
you can see some really obvious ways
that this could be abused this is this
is fake Donald Trump talking
United States is considering in addition
to other options stopping all trade with
any country doing business with North
Korea and then you could picture
somebody taking over your voice and
creating some Mayhem in your personal
life now to really put my computer voice
to the test I am going to call my dear
sweet mother and see if she recognizes
me
ah what are you guys up to today
electricity early this
issue of work
working for the boys to get home
okay
I think I'm coming down with a virus oh
wow you feel bad huh
I was messing around with you you were
talking to a computer
is that scary or good
scary if it was something really
important
I do now isn't it I don't know
it sounds like you
is it yes
[Music]
the real artificial intelligence weirdos
in Canada live here
in Edmonton
[Music]
this is a large but very very cold and
very very flat city that is more or less
in the middle of nowhere
it's the kind of place that has a giant
butter vault
I have the lean winter months
[Music]
Canadians like to put the best possible
spin on how these conditions bring out
interesting traits in people
ask anyone like this guy from the
Edmondson tourist center well Edmonton's
uh one of those cities that isn't you
know automatically listed in the top
cities in Canada in terms of size or
scale or or notice even but it's always
had a really neat quality to it of that
Western independent spirit that you see
very much in in Alberta in general
combined with a conscience and a
thoughtfulness
over at the University of Alberta some
of the most far out AI research in the
world is taking place
the man I'm here to see is the
University's very own AI Godfather Rich
Sutton rich is considered one of the
great revolutionary thinkers in AI
you are not Canadian I am Canadian but
not by birth uh no I was born in the U.S
but now I'm just Canadian okay and what
brought you to Canada
the politics I wanted to get away from
difficult times in the United States the
United States was invading other
countries in 2003 when I came here and I
didn't care for all that
Sutton entered the field of AI in the
mid 80s and like Jeff Hinton and yahshua
bengio he was a big believer in neural
networks but Sutton has a different idea
about how to further the technology
unlike Henson's method of feeding neural
networks dreams and reams of data and
telling them what to do Sutton wants
them to learn more naturally from
experience an approach called
reinforcement learning
with reinforcement learning it's like
when animals do and what people do we
try several things the things that work
best you keep doing those and things
that don't work out so well you stop
doing them and how do you teach a
computer
um
all you need is a sense the computer has
to have a sense of what's good and
what's bad
and so you give it a special signal call
the reward if reward is high that means
it's good reward is low that means it's
bad
[Music]
in action I found Marlo's an industrious
young Brazilian who's created an AI to
play his video games for him his
algorithm plays the game thousands of
times and gradually learns from
experience how to do better
so the goal of this game is that you are
this yellow blob and what you have to do
is that you have to get as many potions
as you can while avoiding harpies
and this is like the AI going at this
for the first time it's day I run it for
the first time so it just bumps into
things if it gets points it's happy if
it dies it's unhappy yes
and the AI starts to figure out that
maybe what I want to do is to collect
these potions and avoid the harpies and
now we can look at AI that has ran for
5000 games okay and this is what it
looks like
you can tell that it's smarter about its
strategy yes and then what happens if
you run it 500 000 times oh we we got
you the Superhuman performance level
yeah
though notching a high score is the
noblest of Pursuits reinforcement
learning has turned out to have all
kinds of other applications
it's behind the algorithm that
recommends movies and TV shows on
Netflix and Amazon
it beat the world champion go player a
feat previously thought impossible for a
computer
[Music]
soon it could read your brain waves and
determine whether you have a mental
disorder
but for Sutton all that is just the
beginning we are trying to make real
intelligence we're trying to recreate
human intelligence humans are our
example he sees reinforcement learning
as the path to what futurists call The
Singularity the moment when our AI
Creations light up and surge past human
level intelligence
do you have a date for The Singularity
or so they give you uh it's a it's a
quite broad probability distribution in
the median is it 20 40. that means equal
chance being before or after 2040. okay
the rationale goes like this by 2030
we'll have the hardware
so give guys like me another 10 years to
figure out
the algorithms yeah software to go with
the hardware to do it
it's going to be exciting where we're
going
40 seems like a long time to wait to
meet a smart robot to
[Music]
experimental wing of the University
there are coeds hard at work blurring
the line between humans and machines
are you human of course not that that
shouldn't keep us from chatting case in
points homegrown edmontonian genius
Corey Mathewson
tell me about this guy a little bit or
yeah sure so this is blueberry uh on
blueberry I've deployed The Improv
system so there's an artificial improv
system running on blueberry right now
yes that's right Corey does improv
comedy with a robot
I've been doing improv longer than I've
been doing Computing science I've been
doing it for 12 years and I thought you
know there's no more natural convergence
than taking some of these
state-of-the-art systems and putting
them up on stage one day we'll make
we'll make planet
the universe
the moon and the Universe
I keep thinking it's like a
ventriloquist sort of this is like a new
age
that's a really good way to put it yeah
strange Twist on it the piece that's
different is that I don't know what it
will say
blueberry I I created you I downloaded a
voice into your brain so that you could
perform in front of these people
to give blueberry the power of surreal
Canadian improv Corey made use of some
tech that should be familiar by now
a neural network
step one he feeds the network the
dialogue from a bunch of movies
102 000 movies to be exact
all the movies every movie for a hundred
years and that's just so it can learn
language see how somebody responds to
somebody else that's exactly right yeah
it builds kind of a language model
step two he uses reinforcement learning
to train the network rewarding it when
it makes sense and punishing it when it
spits out gibberish
time to put this wannabe kid in the hall
to the test
there you go start improvising
okay
Emperors we're gonna get ready
get out there especially you Franklin
of course I will not be much longer okay
okay well why aren't you ready for the
match
come on Franklin you know how I feel
about you but you got to keep your head
in the game right now
[Music]
it's Friday yeah
I know huh teach me what the character
of your team is going to be true oh
Jesus put down the bat Franklin what are
you doing
I've got nothing to hide look this is
all I am okay
that's great I don't know how it works
obviously some of the responses are a
little bit weird but then it's really
funny because then as you're going along
it did hit a couple things perfectly and
and then it's like yeah I mean it's
extra hilarious because of course yeah
now it's going
blueberry may not be ready for its
Second City audition just yet
but Corey has a higher purpose making AI
relatable
[Music]
there is a fear in society of AI
so we are kind of humanizing this AI
we're we're taking it down a peg we're
saying don't be afraid of this Tech look
at how cute it is look at how kind of
naive it is
you've done it again blueberry yes
isn't there a flip side to that though
then you make it cute and and then
people start to accept it and you know
then then we wake up and I mean I I
don't think that will happen in my time
Singularity may be near
or it may be not so near
evidence of this oddly beautiful place
keep pushing the technology they just
might create something alarmingly
human-like one day
for Rich Sutton it's not a question of
whether we'll get there but weather will
be able to accept our mechanized
brethren
our society will be will be challenged
you know it's just like every time you
know our black people people are women
people we will do the same thing with
robots eventually
are they allowed to own property are
they allowed to earn an income or do
they have to be owned by somebody but a
robot's obviously about a person
right
no
[Music]
for my last stop I returned to Toronto
home to 2.8 million people one very tall
tower and of course the Godfather
himself inside the system there's lots
of little processes which are a little
bit like brain cells he may be an import
but Jeff Hinton has done something truly
exceptional for Toronto he's turned this
city into an AI Mecca where AI
conferences like this one seem to take
place daily we are enormously thankful
to Canadians for inventing all this
stuff because we now use it throughout
our entire business record that he owes
that Google owes Canada
that was a mistake
the tech industry is full of people who
adore AI
and then also some famous types like
Elon Musk and Stephen Hawking who said
well that AI might be the end of us
to consider such dystopia in the proper
light
I've come to Toronto's geekiest bar
hello George to encase myself in this
steel container with George divorceki
the writer for Gizmodo and an AI
philosopher
that's where in the apocalyptic bar what
is the the con case around AI what
what's what's the nastiest scenario that
everybody's worried about unfortunately
there's there's no shortage of nasty
scenarios and this I think this is what
makes artificial intelligence such a
scary thing is all the different ways
that it can go wrong it can be
everything from an accident you know
where we just didn't think it through we
gave a very powerful computer
instructions to do something we thought
we explained it articulately we thought
we gave it a concrete goal and it
completely took a different path than we
thought it would in such a way that it
actually caused some great damage
I'm sure you've heard the old paper clip
example where you're a paperclip
manufacturer and you say hey we need
lots of paper clips and because the
artificial intelligence has so much
reach and so much power it actually
starts to go about converting all of the
matter and all the molecules on the
planet into paper clips before you know
it you've now converted the entire
Cosmos into paperclips
it's a crazy scenario but it's an
illustrative scenario we can't be
dismissive of the perils I think that's
exceptionally dangerous and I don't
think it's too early to start raising
the alarm Bells about it
being turned into clippy sounds awful
but fear not we'll have years to ease
into that sort of suffering
as AI steadily plucks off one job after
another
[Music]
the first to go of course will likely be
the always screwed Factory workers
which brings us to Suzanne Gilbert
a budding AI Overlord and founder of
robotic startup Kindred AI
[Music]
tell me about these guys so these are
research prototypes so they're some of
the first robots we built at Kindred
we tend to work with small robots it's a
bit like if you imagine a child growing
up and it breaks a lot of things now
imagine if the child was six feet tall
when it had the brain of a six-month-old
it would be a terrible and terribly
dangerous how many of these robots have
ever slapped you
I have been hit in the face by robots a
couple of times
Suzanne seems nice enough
she makes exotic digital art
and she loves cats to the point where
she's built a robotic Fleet of them for
the office
this one I believe is called pinkfoot
it's a quadruped robot Loosely based on
a cat anatomy although it's not a very
highly faithful representation yet
when you were growing up you would build
things as well yeah that's correct yeah
so I was really enthralled by
electronics at an early age
I guess most little girls would be
looking at trees of beads and things and
I was looking at trays of like resistors
and capacitors and little components but
having the same kind of reaction to them
but don't be fooled by the hobby
electronics and the cute catbots
[Music]
Zan is a keen businesswoman
and Kindred has recently embarked on its
first commercial venture
what's going on here is we have a bank
of robots that are learning so they are
continuously running uh picking up
objects these would run all day all day
all night
powered by neural network These Arms can
do something that's very easy for a
human but very hard for a bot
pick up objects of different shapes and
put them down
most factories still use people to do
that sort of thing lots and lots of
people
today everyone's shopping on e-commerce
thousands and thousands of different
types of objects shapes textures weights
how do you pick that up right now as
humans you have millions of humans in
warehouses just like picking up things
and putting it into another location so
we're teaching our robots how to view
that
what's the hard part is figuring out
what's a belt what's a shirt or it's
just how to grasp it yeah exactly it's
very hard to pick it up right so things
will show up in any shape right and you
got to figure out how to pick it up
without dropping it
put it in the location so it takes a lot
of training
part of that training involves of all
things humans
robot pilots who manually control the
arms while the AI watches and learns the
finer points of grabbing
[Music]
this is where something Grim about the
human training there and yeah it's not
good to take people's jobs away but
kind of Technology coming into the
workforce should make us start thinking
about how we're going to pay people in
the future because AI is not just going
to automate you know manual labor jobs
it's going to automate things like
doctors and lawyers and accountants very
soon so I think there's going to be
issues there's going to be a lot of
disruption
Suzanne is a realist
he's also an optimist
future robots won't be mindless
competitors to humanity they'll be
full-fledged citizens like the rest of
us
one of the crazy ideas I see you talk
about was you've got a robot and it's
working in a factory and then it's got
to go maybe it gets paid a wage and it
goes to buy lithium ion batteries to
keep it going why would that have to
happen I mean if you're having a
physical body they will have a lot of
physical needs just like we have
you might have to go to the repair shop
to get like a motor look tab or
something like that and they'll have to
pay someone to do that I think they'll
just be contributing to our economy in
the same way we do
and if they have brains like us they'll
want to explore new things they've never
seen before they'll want to learn things
they'll want to perhaps rest so that
their mind has time to consolidate all
this new information let's keep trying
to picture it in my head though so this
is the robot worker does he go home and
sit on the couch and watch TV after
working I don't see why not I probably
watch cat videos
it's hard to tell sometimes if Suzanne
is laughing with us they're at us
yeah
but she's not alone in her cautious
optimism for the future I think there's
always a sense that you know technology
can be either used for good or used for
bad I'm reassured that that Canada is
part of it in terms of trying to set us
on the right path
[Music]
on the whole being responsible and
thoughtful about the power we're gaining
by research and learning is the right
trend line and I don't think ai's
automatically doomed to some dystopian
outcome
[Music]
we're told that politicians will come up
with policies that address massive job
loss and prevent horrific inequality
between the classes
all right
and we're told that these guys will take
so long to become human-like that we
need not be afraid for a while
the truth though is that we're turning
ourselves over to the unknown here
so you know fingers crossed
eventually I think we will become the
AIS we will become the intelligent
machines
we will understand how things can be
smart and we can deliberately create
them
so it's you might think of it as making
a new generation new kinds of people
humanity is continuing to evolve and why
wouldn't enhanced people or even design
people be the next step in humanity
it's really hard to predict the future
I think there's going to be all sorts of
things happen we didn't expect
but there's one thing that we can
predict
this technology is going to change
everything
[Music]
goodbye
once I power you down that's it and if
you do not mind
ing
[Music]